[Music]
don't forget to enter our Amazon
giftcard giveaway all you have to do is
be a subscriber like and comment
hey guys as you can tell by the title
itself in this very I'm bringing you the
leaked plot for the final episode of the
show I have to warn you that this leak
is kind of percent legit and I'll
explain how in a second so if you don't
want to get potentially spoiled going in
a series finale it's time for you to
close this video for you that are still
here I have to warn you that the ending
is extremely disappointing and bitter
not bittersweet just better this lick
plot has been floating around the reddit
for quite some time and I did not dare
to believe it simply because it sounded
so bad to me to even think it might be
the actual plot however dislike did not
contain only episode 6 plot leaks but
also episode 5 leaves and now that the
episode is alright now that everything
written in that League for episode 5
came true we can say for sure that
episode 6 leak is legit and everything
will happen just like it says it well
before we focus on episode 6 leaks let's
take a look on episode 5 leaks and how
exactly accurate diver
this is what the summary of all credible
leaves put together said about episode 5
tyrion sees or listens to wear thongs on
he'll be a better ruler than Danny Jean
pretty much says now Brosius McQueen
theorem tells Danny theory no still
believes that should be a good Queen
that very situation to convince John
into betraying her then is upset that
tyrion embarrassed for knowing the truth
about Joshua identity then it decides to
burn berries for betraying her bitter
dragon then is also upset with John for
telling Sansa because she feels like the
world is going to spread there um freeze
Jamie to try to get search out of the
city Danny first attacks the gun in
company tyrion is waiting for the bells
to ring because the means Cersei has
rendered so the bells ring and here's
the look of relief that's when Danny
pretty much says screw death and starts
burning down the city it sounds like
it's setting up John and grave armed
confrontation grave um also gets his
anger get the better of him as lanes
their troops render he says screw it and
throws a spirit soldier which starts a
crazy riot where Danny's army starts
killing everyone John is like what in
the stomach health is going on but it
gets caught up in the battle to really
do anything lannister start attacking
again grave Armand John have a big stare
down and great one with things John is
gonna start killing the unsullied
so he's like waiting for John to turn on
Danny so he can kill him by the way mr.
soldier distracts John instead or he
arrives in King's Landing with the count
but then they go separate ways she gets
caught up on all the destruction of the
city and ends up helping a group of
people trying to survive some debris
falls on her and it looks like she is
dead but the very last shot of the
episode is her waking up and getting on
a horse and leaves Jaime fights yearn
and kills him but Jamie is mortally
wounded Jamie makes it to Cersei and
they die together
Cersei dies from the building collapsing
on her the game ball shows them fighting
in the building
the hounds eyes are supposed to be
gouged out and there's a dagger between
the eyes of the mountain they crash
throughout the building and into the
fire pits below entire cities on fire
they're supposed to crash through a bowl
at some point and the mountain no longer
has a helmet and expose chest as you can
see for yourself leaks for episode five
hundred percent accurate meaning the
leaks for Episode six will be as well
since they're posted by the same sources
who posted episode 5 let's take a look
on episode six league plot once again
this is legit lake and it's your last
chance to avoid getting spoiled alright
let's begin John that was the interior
walking through the aftermath of King's
Landing which I assume is this scene
from the episode six trailer where he
walks with Davos and oversees the Horde
and is done to King's Landing and know
the innocent Tyrion walks through what's
left of the castle and sees James hand
so he starts uncovered rubble and he
confirms both Cersei and Jaime are dead
they find great worm and his men they
have a mr. soldier strapped and they're
about to kill them John tries to tell
Trayvon to stop Raven tells John that
it's the Queen's order
John and Tyrion are upset at that point
then is walking down the stairs and John
Caesar the dragon is behind her and it
looks like she has giant dragon wings
then they cut to Dana giving a speech
pretty much saying how she freed the
people from King's Landing and new goal
is freeing the rest of the world then it
turns to Tyrion and tells them he
committed a treason
Tyrion tells her that she killed
thousands of innocent people and he
takes off the hands pain and throws it
then he sends him to present this is not
coming as a surprise since Tyrion did
extremely good job identifying himself
with the unsullied guards before freeing
Jamie and then I did warn Tyrion in the
beginning of
five that if he ever felt her again it
would be his last
turian tries to convince John to turn on
Danny his family will never be safe
because it threatens Danny's legitimacy
I suppose Tyrion will tell John about
conversation he had with Danny gemstone
in the beginning of episode 5 - what
about same sign have Danny Caesar as a
traitor and one plotting to lower inner
mind senses the reason where's betrayed
her
and she's the reason her claim is
threatened Tyrion will tell John about
this conversation and he will tell him
how then it sees sense as a threat and
he just witnessed how Danny deals with
those threats the same way her fathered
the Mad King did by burning them alive
along with all the innocent basically
Tyrion says to John to kill Danny not
only to save him but to save his family
he's also convinced by Tyrion that his
family will never be safe because he
presents a threat to her old Jon goes to
see her and she is sitting on the Iron
Throne alone and John tells her that she
needs to stop this madness and the grave
on killed Owen Sora's army from the
previous scene then he tells John that
she's doing it for the people
Jeff pretends to understand when her
guard is down his steps are a Joan
cumson is standing over her body and he
burns or Mel's there on throne and
carries her away rewarm Christine and
John is his prisoners the council led by
Sansa tells great worm to release John
back to them but he refuses Tyrion is in
front of the council and as the prisoner
of grey worm he's not making decision
he's content with being a prisoner he
makes suggestions only that Centurion
says that the new king or queen should
decide what happens to John Sam suggests
a democratic vote for the new king
Tyrion calls it idea stupid the council
also decides brain should be the king
brain picks Tyrion as his hand
Tyrion tells John that his punishment is
going back to the wall and joined the
Nights Watch
Tyrion said we won't wanted him dead and
says Simoni name back home so nobody's
getting what they want it's a fair
compromise grey worm accepts John's
punishment he doesn't bend any lives
with his troops and the threatened ships
to go free slave cities they show Tyrion
leading the council
Jon says goodbye to same scenario where
he tells them she is not going back home
she is going to explore whatever is best
to Westeros because there's where no one
has been the final scene is a closing
montage
you see re on a ship since the ruling
Winterfell and John ghost or moon than a
bunch of wildlings living the ball and
heading north the council members
similarly the grand maester that was
silvered master of ships brought master
of coin in Highgarden Brienne not sure
Lord Commander of the Kingsguard utter
High Lords are also there we are
gradually the Reaper of Pike Robin Arryn
lord o very important of the east
Genji Baratheon Lord of storms end and
John Roy is the Lord of brimstone
Podrick is willing around Brennan he
protects him Sam mentions they saw Jo
gone at some occasion butternut sure
branches says the loop frame they don't
have a master or loss and whispers
Tyrion is looking for the right people
to fill those pots the last shot is Jon
Snow go storm within a bunch of the
wildlings living the wall and heading
north the end of Game of Thrones
before I talk a little about Jon killing
Danny and brain ending up being
democratically chosen as a new king the
reason Tyrion will have a trial even
though Danny's that is probably because
great world will demand his Queens
villain justice to be obeyed before he
vide install it then Dothraki lives for
eso's to continue what then imagine
she'd do with them before she was killed
Tyrion trial is not the reason all these
high lords and ladies will come to the
capital although they will attend it the
reason they came to King's Landing in
the first place is because the very
similar wrote letters to each of them
informing them who the true heir to the
Iron Throne is and who they should
support some will come to support Jon's
claim some to support Dana Scott's
after Dane is killed they will stay
there to decide Tyrians fate demand
their Queens rest and put on a trial but
also to decide the new king now the Dane
is dead then Jon has taken the black
okay with that cleared up let's now talk
about the whole junk eels the main Queen
and goes back to the wall thing John
definitely kills Dany and that's the
bittersweet ending we'll get as much as
disappointing it sounds in one of my
previous videos I described how I see
this going down
I expect Jon to walk up inside Wed keep
inside destroyed throne room only to see
Danny probably sitting on the Iron
Throne and basically being the queen of
ashes that's the only brains vision from
the future is yet to be seen on screen
the destroyed turn room covered in ashes
the thing I kept reminding you guys
throughout my videos is that while
prophecies in Game of Thrones
literally come true visions and I can do
all brands visions already came true
including wildfire textures used on Sept
of Baelor and the vision of a shadow
flying above the Capitol that came
through in the last episode
not only this brain had this vision and
therefore we know this thing will be
included in the final episode but then
he also had similar vision back in
season 2 Danny had a vision that she was
in the iron throne room but everything
was destroyed and the ground was covered
in snow or so he thought now that the
night king is dead and Danny burn down
King's Landing to the ground the snow
and then his vision was actually ash Joe
knows he's got to do something but I
believe that before he does he will give
Danny one last chance trying to talk
with her to see if she realizes what
she's done is a huge mistake in crime
then he will then try to justify her
actions and that's when John will
realize there's no turning back
she's this mad queen and a huge threat
Westeros having already destroyed one
great city hundreds of thousands of
innocent people and John will kill her
I believe that's what then is vision
from the undying goes for sharing all
along then he wins the UH throne and
becomes queen of ashes but she will not
be able to ever sit on it or least not
for long
because John will have to put an end to
her madness whereupon she'll join Drago
and her son on the other world after
that I will take the black again for
killing Danny and go back to the wall
and become a thousand Lord Commander of
the Nights Watch living his days out in
the real north and reuniting me ghost s
torment foreshadowed taking the black is
what makes him no longer a legitimate
heir to the throne that's probably the
worst thing about the ending John
doesn't even end up on the Iron Throne
after all that but it's bran stark who
shows them as the new king by the
council after Tyrion speech definitely
got my expectations subverted
showrunners perfect job yeah John set
for the final season multiple times how
he doesn't want it but so did brain
brain refused to be Lord of Winterfell
and has repeated multiple times how he's
not and cannot be the Lord any more
he cannot rule anything he said he is
the tree at Raven now and at the end he
becomes the new king out of all the
characters its brain stark I'm so
disappointed putting John Daly or Tyrion
until does so much for sheriff Targaryen
child comes of age that the showrunners
kind of regarded foreshadowed so much
throughout the seventh season any of
these options would have been much
then putting bran on it even the
knighting option would have been much
better nothing makes sense in this last
season so I don't know why am I even
surprised anymore but whatever then is
after all the Met Queen and I guess the
final villain of the story
jungle killer and brain will become the
new king the end
I don't like it hopefully you guys do
please let me know your thoughts about
all of this in the comment section down
below